Oh cabbie can I call you kevie now
alright first of all I want to say this
that I do admire you I appreciate a
vignette instead of a condition what I
have a condition to working out I have a
city I'm allergic
what's the permits the condition of
basically what happens when my heart
rate elevates yeah I get sore so that's
the main issue that I'm trying to get
over what do you know just didn't work
you just didn't work oh okay let's be
honest yes be honest me channel the GED
answer me
alright you're lazy physical fitness and
working out is how you start your day
you give what you want to be mentally
everything else follows you wouldn't
know what I go through also don't have
breasts well fill my arm is moist that's
because you have a raincoat Aloha - what
a Patagonia is but listen to me okay I'm
having talk to you about your condition
I don't think that this is what I came
for
okay you remind me on my parents do
gonna punch me in the eye - and you
gonna leave me out the bus stop how
about you spend a week with me want to
do that man you know that's on camera
right it's what you do [ __ ] yeah I would
alright let's do it you spent a week
with me alright
the holidays you figure it out wishes
get it oh my god 2010 20 pounder today
20 pounds you're gonna lose 20 pounds
he's gonna lose 20 pounds are you gonna
do it with me
all right if you don't do it then I
rather have to talk to you again in life
because your own mark on it all right
I'll see you in your lesson at the end
of this conversation I'm not gonna do
this with you a lot of the time take
yourself stairs and I'll take you
serious your hands I solve it what he
has soft okay David
[Music]